sh just a quick announcement before we
get started make sure your cell phones
are are either turned off or just m
silence and then if you can all just
move up front so we have the back sides
available as people for in
[Silence]
asbb allahar
ill
[Silence]
as
f
allahar
[Silence]
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
sub
[Silence]
muham
my dear brothers respected
Elders beloved youth brothers and
sisters we thank Allah subhana tala for
keeping us alive one more day on the
path of Islam on the and allowing me and
you to enter his house and worship him
in the manner that pleases him I ask
subhana to accept from me and accept
from you the so very little we do in his
path mean and a bear witness there is no
deed worthy of worship except for Allah
subhana wa tala and Prophet Muhammad s.
wasam is his last and final messenger
for surely who Allah subhana tala
chooses to guide None Shall can misguide
and he who chooses to misguide n shall
can guide him back to the path and we
seek refuge in Allah from darkness of
ourselves and evil of our Deeds for
Allah is all knowing and all seeing what
his creation
does whether we it or we don't like
it the time does not stop for any
man and that is true for any woman or
any being that lives upon this Earth
just we started yesterday the year
of 2024 and it's coming to an end just
we were fasting not too long ago
for Ramadan in 2024 that Ramadan is 2025
is knocking again there are many people
and friends and relatives who were here
with us maybe weeks ago months ago hours
ago and those people are no longer with
us as such what are we doing to prepare
for that time what are we doing to get
ready to meet Allah subhana wa ta'ala as
Allah subhana has mentioned in the Quran
oh human oh mankind indeed you are
laboring towards your
Lord with a great exertion and you will
meet
it Allah created hum kind and fashion
them in the best form making them in the
finest stature to go back and forth
through life's path and task either
saving themselves through righteous
Deeds or destroying themselves through
sins as Allah subhana T has mentioned
the
Quran that he has created the man in the
best
form and then the human form Falls below
the beautiful stature that Allah sub has
created for the human
being Allah created us to
be something and somebody that even the
Mal prostrated
to and then we push ourselves so low
that the humankind the man had to look
at a raven to see how to bury a dead
body Allah
also and indeed the mankind is creating
weakness we are weak
we are Hollow within
ourselves there's pits and falls on the
road to Allah subhana wa tala there
isn't anyone who has an experience who
doesn't experience worries and sorrows
and difficulty life's trials toss them
left to right and they interact as they
interact with their families childrens
and peers afflictions befall them like
clouds obscuring sun and moon veiling
their light than they strive desperately
to escape what has befallen them seeking
Refuge or hiding in places to flee from
their afflictions they knock on people's
closed doors but fail to knock on the
door of Allah subhah wa ta'ala that is
forever open and never closed they spend
time sharing their worries and sorrows
with people despite their weakness and
limited humility of a human being
instead they do not care or think about
sharing their sorrows and difficulties
with the one who has created everything
and nothing is hidden from him Allah
subhana tala
alone the one who responds to the
distressed when they call upon him and
removes the evil one whose hand is the
Dominion of all things and who protects
and no and none can protect against him
if a such if such a person flees to
Allah subhana wa ta'ala
he would awaken he meaning Allah subhana
T would awaken his Consciousness purify
their soul and cleanse their heart and
bestow upon them the aid and success and
Grant them insight into knowing him
along with abundant Paths of drawing
closer to Allah subhana tala among which
is guiding them to Treasures from the
treasures of
paradise and a gate from the gates of
paradise which they had neglected after
the worldly life and alienation from
their lord distracted them from
realizing ing Allah subhana tala and its
effects Hadith mentioned in on the
authority
[Silence]
of wasallam said to
abdah say there is nothing more power
except there there's there is no might
nor power except with Allah subhana tala
and for his treasures for it is a
treasure from the treasures of
paradise regardless of what we go
through on a daily
basis and Allah subh has left us with
abundance of things to practice in our
daily lives through all afflictions to
raise us in ranks and there there is not
an Affliction that befalls a Believer
except Allah either removes their sins
with it and elevates them higher in the
ranks of
Jenna as such you see an eagle flying
and as the eagle Rises it has strong
headwinds and those headwinds are not
there to deter the bird from its flight
but it's meant to elevate him higher and
higher and higher
and that's the condition of us
Muslims our return to Allah subhana tala
is through those pitfalls and those
afflictions and those distresses and
those stresses and all of those
afflictions that we go through in our
daily
lives but remembering that there is a
path to Allah subhana wa ta'ala Allah
has revealed those beautiful words to us
through which we can seek his guidance
and his reassurance insurance and a
guaranteed way to enter the
paradise
Asam said in mentioned
[Silence]
in Al wasallam asked should I not direct
you to a gate from Gates of paradise I
said of
course
wasam said there is no might or power
except with Allah so understanding that
these are just not words a lot of times
our struggle our
frustration comes out because first and
foremost we don't understand the
background for these
words as it is mentioned in the Quran
when
unus is tested by Allah subhana
tala and then he
says right understanding the background
that Unice had to go through to acquire
those
words and what it means and that's why
for
some they mention when you raise your
hands to ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
at least pretend or make a face a
crying face show some sign that you are
in stress you have some anxiety to show
Allah subhana wa ta'ala and if you have
raised your hands and within couple of
minutes of raising your hands your mind
is now wondering what's for dinner and
what's on the TV and where have to hang
out put your hands down don't continue
with a Dua that Dua is no longer
accepted because now you're just
wandering through
routines I want to take a time and just
mention something real quick before we
continue on this for for my brothers and
sisters especially who come from South
Asian countries we have this tradition
back home and please understand I'm not
trying to create a a a diversion or or
or or a a a a crack through it I'm just
trying to draw your attention that
raising your hands IM raising his hands
after the Dua after the Salah in Dua is
shown in Hadith but it's not something
that did on the regular but the the Dua
within itself is in the
Salah the Salah is the part you're
making Dua in when you're in the when
you're in the when you're sitting
between two s that's the time to make
Dua to Allah subhana
tala Allah
those are the duas you should be making
in that
time and that's why when you pray
sometimes behind
some the the distance between two SAS is
little
longer the time for is little longer the
time for S is a little
longer take that time
to ask Allah subhana tala for your
issues and let me say this the best Dua
to make is the one that comes from your
heart when you're in the most
pain remember Allah subhana tala knows
every
language every language that we have
today on the face of the Earth is from
Allah subhana
tala Allah subhana has mentioned this
every single thing we have today
regardless how fast the AI Computing
gets how fast the quantum physics get
how fast the quantum computer becomes
how fast the quantum chips become today
for the computers it is from Allah
subhana tala itself and nothing
else Allah says in the Quran that he
taught Adam every single thing every
single thing was taught to
Adat so there's nothing that exists on
the face of the Earth and that's why
usually I take an issue
when I talk to people and they don't
want to learn astronomy and they don't
want to learn physics and quantum
physics I I know I'm looking at one of
my brothers you know I said I told this
story a long time ago you know it was
what 12:00 in the morning I gave one of
my dearest brother a long lecture in
quantum physics and in Islam and after
an hour he kept smiling at me and then I
asked him what did you understand he
said you know what
nothing and he said H said it's okay
don't tell me again I said okay I won't
it's not for everybody but understand
that is from Allah subhana tala nothing
that we have today from the of is not
from Allah subhana tala it matters how
we use it to get close to Allah subhana
tala everything should be a way to Allah
not away from
Allah let's get back to to the the the
current topic on hand the the par the
the treasures from the paradise the
treasur from from the paradise of Allah
subhana
tala understanding that we need to
increase in the enduring of our
righteous Deeds as mentioned by IM Ahmed
andan in their books he said it was
asked to wasallam and what are they what
are these right just Deeds that we go
through enduring them meaning that we
kept keep on doing them and doing them
and sallallahu alaihi wasallam replied
pay attention to
this some one of the easiest recipes you
will get saying
Allah
alhamdulillah and then Subhan
Allah easiest things Subhan
alhamdulillah
how long does that take how long does
that take
us how long does that take to come out
of my
tongue
nothing how much effort did I put into
it
nothing and then remembering these
things on a daily basis when we
do this next Hadith that is mentioned is
from
and it's mentioned
that has taught us this Hadith to Shield
us and protect us from the effects of
the Satan of the
shaitan right and for us understand
something and I think some of us don't
understand this we all have a Shan that
is with us that has been put next to us
who Whispers in our ear through out the
whole
day and that's why it's recommended that
we read the last two suras in the
Quran here this
Hadi so you read this simple statement
when you're leaving the house in the
morning make sure you put your right
foot out and just make this Dua to Allah
subh and thean himself is
wondering and he says how can I misguide
a human that who's asked Allah for his
protection a Shan something that is
created above Allah subhana
no Allah created him as
well and our job is to seek protection
24/7 from the effects of of this of this
entity and then I'm going to draw your
attention to this Hadith inshallah
before we come to conclusion on the
first seron and if you guys can move
forward there's space in front of you
please take that space we're getting
full on the back side so just we can
keep people coming
in mentioned in
B said
[Silence]
this is one of the best
recipes for your troubles in life how
many of us get up at night either to
drink of water or we have to do the rest
we have to use the restroom or for any
other reason or the kids you know one of
the kids is up and we're trying to put
them back to sleep take that time to
remember these beautiful
words who awakens at night and
says there is there is no deity except
for Allah without any Partners to him
belongs all the Dominion to him belongs
all the
praise and he is all he's over all
things competent say this statement and
then follow away with
alhamdulillah
Subhan and after that he says
says oh Allah forgive
me and we have to understand something
the worldly life is what it
is it's up and
down let me draw your attention to a
narration and inshallah that would help
us you know kind of feel what we feel on
a daily
basis is still alive and present in
Medina among sahab
and sah are coming to wasallam and
saying one day our IM is here and one
day it's here
whatam is right there you're sitting
with you're learning from him you're
going to Jihad with
him imagine our
condition how far removed are we from
almost 1500 years I'm rounding up don't
don't come after me say well you said
the Hijra you're wrong I'm rounding it
up not rounding
down we're so further away
from and we're struggling so the
struggle is there but understand one day
we will have this and one day we won't
have
it right the things are good and things
are
bad a lot of the stuff that we me I I
say with me and you all have in your
lives today once we struggled for it and
cried to Allah for it and now we don't
even realize we have it but what is the
best ticket out I will die and so shall
you as om used to famously say today
they
announce that died and that died and
then a day will come they will
say and they they will come and say Omar
has died too so we're all going to die
as I mentioned in the beginning of
the you are walking towards your lord
you're walking in that direction and
indeed one day you will meet him through
whatever struggles you and I have but
the ticket out is not amassing another
billion or a million or a couple of more
trillions but the ticket out is
M so Dua
saying and let me finish with the
Hadith the Hadith goes further and it
says or he makes a Dua any Dua after
that right what Dua we make
him whatever Dua you have you don't know
Arabic alhamdulillah don't don't worry
about it say it in
English whatever you want your
life
right whatever you want to make Dua ask
Allah subhana for
it and then the Hadith
continues the effort is there already
right you have already put the first
initial step of working towards that now
he gets up out of the bed and he makes
W and then he
praise the Hadith mentioned that Salah
is guaranteed
accepted guaranteed accepted that
night you
know people go throughout their life
doing research going to libraries
amassing books asking for this and that
and Allah subhana T has given it to us
in such a simple
form I ask Allah subhana to make us from
the folks
who hear these words and get these
recipes in their lives and then become
acting upon it and I ask Allah subhana
to give us the ability to wake up with
that Consciousness in night time to
remember the Dua and to utter the Dua
and then Allah subh accept it at the
face value without looking at our deeds
and may Allah subh gather us he has
gathers today in The Gardens of paradise
[Silence]
alhamdulillah alul
mentioned
inani Hadith on the authority of ab
[Silence]
so
said that some of the sahab in the
Medina era were quite
distraught Brothers if you have a spot
in front of you please take that spot
where we're getting really pushed into
the hallway outside please help me out
here just if there's a spot empty in
front of you please take that spot
so imagine a time in in Medina era when
things are flourishing and and and the
condition of Muslims is getting better
and better and the money is Flowing now
and there is still a divide amongst some
sahabah and some
sahaba so is complaining
toam he says oh messenger of Allah s
alhi wasallam the wealthy people have
taken all the
rewards they pray pray as we pray they
fast as we fast but then they give sodak
from their excess of their
wealth because they have extra to give
they give extra and I want to just draw
your attention to a
caveat all of us have heard this
narration when
abak brought every single thing he owns
toh wasallam by the way it's the same
time when Allah when is giving hundreds
upon hundreds upon hundreds of camels
fully ladened with everything that is
needed to travel and
fight so keep that in
mind when the when the narration
mentions AB gave every single thing in
the house it means he didn't have much
to give to begin with but whatever he
owned he
gave used to famously say I need two
things from Abu
Bakr the night he spent with in the cave
during hij and the day he gave
everything in his house and Omar and Abu
Bak can have every single good de I've
done so it's the mentality of giving not
how much you give so wasallam says to
him has Allah not given you something
you can give as s meaning you don't have
money but you can do sodak every time
you praise Allah subhana tala
right so these are just beautiful
beautiful recipes for us imagine you
have you're saying these words Allah is
considering it a Sak in your account but
he's also crediting your account for
saying those
words
imagine give you a simple example examp
imagine y you pay your taxes right and
then the government puts it back all the
money in your in your account too and
they say you pay the taxes but your
money is back
too Nobody Does that so what we need to
do is take advantage of this blessing
that Allah subana tala has given us and
take advantage of these
things and continue doing better in
Allah's path I ask Allah subh to unite
us as an ofam as Alat wasam himself has
envisioned it I ask Allah subh to guide
us to guide us to the better of the path
I ask Allah subh to make us from the
people who unite hearts and not divide
Hearts we ask Allah subhana to accept
every single Deed from us at his face
value and he does not look at our
condition as human beings or as Muslims
we ask Allah subhana tala to make us
people who Aid our brothers and sisters
wherever they are without being
judgmental of where they are in their
religious C
we ask Allah subhana tala to make our
children from the progeny of muham we
ask Allah subhana tala that he does not
take us from this Earth until Allah
subhana himself is completely satisfied
and happy with us and when he does take
us away from this Earth the last words
that roll out of our mouth are muham and
Allah grant us the C from the of through
the hands
ofat ask Allah
to provide our brothers and sisters
Muslims who are struggling everywhere
with victories that are true
Injustice may Allah subh Aid them and
better their their their their
conditions first and foremost our
brothers and sisters struggling in Gaza
our brothers sisters in palistine our
brother and sisters in Syria our brother
and sisters in China and Burma our
brothers and sisters in everywhere else
they are struggling to and especially
our brothers and sisters in Sudan
if you don't know the condition they're
currently are going through one of the
hardest
hit food shortages in that country may
Allah subh feed them from the Avenues
and provide them security from the
Avenues we do not know exist we ask
Allah subh to bless this community first
and foremost in every Muslim Community
further we ask Allah remove ailments
from our community and clean our hearts
towards each other we ask Allah subhana
tala to cure the sick in our community
we ask Allah subh those brothers and
sisters from our community who passed in
the last weeks may Allah subh have mercy
upon them and Elevate their statuses and
forgive them and Grant them Jenna
without asking any questions we as
Muslims gather here bear witness that
every single Muslim that has passed
before us was on the true path of
Muhammad Allah subh has ordered us with
an order that he first and foremost told
his angels and then he followed him
himself and he told us to send peace and
blessings on the Blessed Muhammad
s muham muhamad
[Silence]
muh
ill
[Silence]
straighten your lines please fill the
gaps in between may Allah have mercy
upon us
amen ald
[Silence]
am mean
allar
[Silence]
allb ahbar
allar alhamdulillah
[Silence]
amen
Malik allahar
[Silence]
allahar allahar
ahbar
allahar for
[Silence]
assalamu alaykum
okay so inah we'll start with the
announcements I'll make it quick
first and foremost congratulations to
all of the UFA graduates who graduating
or have graduated already may Allah subh
make you guys life successful and pave
the paths and make you a tool from the
tool of Allah subh in his way text
time is coming up there is a way there's
the longest time all the conversation
we've had the last year is how we can
divert our money away from what the the
government is doing with it how can we
put it in better use we have
brothered jabber in the back he can
guide you of how to do your taxes so you
can send the money to the organization
directly all it is is that you're going
to be filing your state taxes a portion
of what you owe or all of it can be
transferred to an organization from
where we can then draw it to provide
scholarships and further educational
needs for people in the community
Through rahma Academy so if you're new
to it you don't understand how to do it
but red has paper work in the back and
all it is that you make a payment to
this organization and show the state
that you've paid your duties and that's
all that matters it's not for fral is
for state only inallah quick reminder
brother Nim's father has passed away
in Pakistan brother Muhammad sh may
Allah have mercy upon his soul and
Elevate statuses and Grant him the
highest ofos in the Jenna there will be
a Dua after brother NAD is here brother
madim you can stand up real quick or
raise your hand if you want to offer
condolences you cannot join him later
tonight he's here right now to do that
we will have a scholar tomorrow night
inshallah for a talk on the status of
Hadith in the Quran the brother is
brother tamim is here can you he's not
even paying attention
okay he's he's right there in the in the
blue th masallah he's a graduate from qu
and he has a PhD he'll be here
tomorrow tomorrow night not tonight
and the talk is in Arabic for 45 minutes
after 15 minutes given to questions
Q&A we'll have somebody translate on his
behalf while the talk is happening so if
you have questions that a lot of people
have in their minds regarding aith or
something else or issues please come and
ask
insh on your way out
show